so we have feeling our own physiology
feeling our own physiology with more
accuracy yes and then two I would say
with subtlety with subtlety yeah and
then noticing shifts based on changes
that are in the external world shifts in
our physiology yeah I mean yeah in her
experience probably could go beyond
physiology into oh when I go into a park
I have these kinds of thoughts I
wouldn't call that necessarily
physiology that's probably that's just
as valid but physiology is a good word
to the example given would be feeling or
calmer how mark I feel walking into a
bar versus walking into a park that's
great okay making it up as we go yeah we
should sell the class this this class
month is on how to feel which is kind of
cool if you think about it I mean that's
what we're learning all the time but
nobody ever taught us so maybe it's cool
to make it into a class let's get let's
get the sales force as a sponsor for
this class Marc Benioff has been very
generous with his partnerships and
sponsorships anyone out there that's
watching from Salesforce I think there's
you know to think about how much feeling
is our whole experience and how little
we think about it it's kind of amazing
and then we think about thinking all the
time all the time there how much thought
is given to thought a lot more than how
much thought or attention is given to
feeling even though feeling is our
primary mode of experiencing the world
yeah yeah that's right that's right
so two oh two would be
I think that might have to be because of
the amount of logic that we have to use
to maneuver the world we're born into
the societal pressures that cause us to
need to use logic more whereas if we
were enabled as a child to use more of
our feeling or intuition and have
society that enabled the use of that
more then that's how we could that's how
that's gonna be talked about in this
transition period you've got we got we
got um we got thrown off course at some
point because we got hurt and then
instead of dealing with the hurt we
found that there was a way to
simultaneously avoid feeling hurt and to
do things that looked productive yeah
and those two tendencies colluded to
create all the machinery of modern life
and now maybe we're starting where those
of us who are in this Western modern
paradigm are starting to realize oops
maybe we can go back to the to the
source the feeling space and then
eventually into class 202 which is what
I've been teaching which is how we are
shifted by other people how our
experience is shifted by other people
interesting okay so how our experience
is shifted by other people so this can
be maybe like example given how you feel
when someone is laughing or angry great
okay and then now is there a 300 what
would be like 301 now we go we leave the
realm of passively noticing our own
experience and in class 3 we start
playing with it deliberately so how to
deliberately open ourselves up to these
kinds of experiences safely or how to
deal with experiences that we've had
that we don't want to have in the future
how to work with this ability
deliberately yeah how to work with this
ability of deliberately deliberately and
safely open ourselves up to these
experiences yes and yeah work with this
ability yep that's yeah people often
want to skip to class 301 yeah me too
everyone wants to know how to do
something but the building blocks are
always crucial everything before then so
just go on to the core and start
shooting three-pointers you don't just
go and start closing million-dollar
deals you got to close those ten dollar
deals yeah so literally going how am I
feeling right now
and even if the answer is I have no idea
literally but I've tried to feel
something you've now passed class 101
and you we can build from there into oh
wow I'm deliberately opening myself up
to this person's energy I'm
understanding how it affects me and then
maybe in class 302 I'm using what I'm
getting to help others consciously we're
doing it all the time unconsciously but
now we can start doing it consciously
yeah okay so so 302 once you start
deliberately and safely working with the
ability then you start feeling how to
help yep this yellow tea okay so then
this would also be me
hmmm this is a big a big part of this in
my opinion at least from the very small
amount of intuitive practice that I've
had with this is that I it's really
important for me to know when I am doing
a process that is energetically
exhausting for me taking on someone
else's experience with trauma or taking
on their their the path the path of
growth for them the integration of the
trauma and the growth because that that
requires me to hold space and all that
so so again when you're working with
this process it's probably one of the
most important things to understand how
you're feeling throughout it because it
can be extremely exhausting important
thing to understand how you yourself are
feeling is the is the foundation of I
want to say it's the foundation of all
growth it doesn't mean you have to be
conscious of it all the time I don't
want to put that pressure on people but
if there's another way to grow into who
you really are that doesn't involve
feeling what you're actually feeling I
don't know it's that that that that's my
that's the limitation of my own
worldview or either that or I'm just
right and there is there is this pathway
that's open to all of us that few of us
take where we grow through our own
experience and much of our own
experiences is is the felt sense but we
can broaden that it's not just what
you're feeling can also be what you're
hearing and seeing and what's coming
through you but having a reference point
for how everything that's showing up
feels in your body feels so crucial yeah
yeah having that reference point and
that's the reference point is 101 and
then one or two developing outlet and
then we can we can package this probably
a way
now but it's just yeah it's quite it's
quite cool we finally were able to
illustrate something on a spectrum but
on a development spectrum so if you feel
your own with subtlety and then you
notice your shifts based on external
world and then you you notice the shifts
from other people and then you
deliberately and safely work with it and
then I wrote helping other people with
the ability like holy crap it sounds
great and then if we wanted to go to
four 402 we never got working with
non-human entities yeah
entities subtler energies other layers
of information subtler energies yeah and
then I mean the dead honest I mean this
stuff that's out there we might not
necessarily believe in but that seems to
show up regularly to people who seem to
have a capacity for it yeah a lot of
this and actually this is part of what
initially got needed the spectrum was
just the ability to if what if we
believe that everything is connected if
we believe that the butterfly effect
exists if we believe that there is all
fibers are connected of every atom of
every molecule of every Planck length
that then there is some sort of ability
then to go from my toroidal form of
energy into your toroidal form of energy
through this interconnected web totally
feeling not only your soul at this
moment but feeling feeling across the
earth to how China currently feels I
think this is very possible feeling how
a dolphin currently feels swimming
through that gorgeous ocean jumping
through the and enjoying that feeling
how that tree that's been alive for
thousands of years feels as its
continuing to nourish that environment
get those resources from the soil and
get the resources from the sunlight
how about how the dolphin feels when
they're being slaughtered in that
Japanese massacre every year do we can
we touch on that or we can bring
awareness to that you just have a water
yeah there's the pain of the dolphin
being slaughtered is now present in this
space yeah the Taiji dolphin drivelines
yeah yeah just just for just for a
moment because I'm not we don't know we
don't know how many people are yeah are
aware of this but government quota
allows over 2000 to be slaughtered or
captured
annually 22,000 are killed so so why
money why money go ahead show the
picture context obviously I would rather
not look at a picture let's not do it on
David Stream but but we just brought
awareness to it but that's that's yeah
that was our I'm sorry Dave it's okay my
role is devil's advocate I appreciate
you're all okay so that was expressing
my preference
yes yes that was okay that was 401 and
then we can just end there and then
we'll for 402 as something to do with
the way we engage with these entities
may be maximized and 402 would be
something like travel interdimensional
travel or something like that
we've now let gone beyond my paygrade a
little bit
I'll have flashes of this totally yeah
all right beautiful good job team we've
nice we'll put this in the bio after the
show as well I'm glad you guys got a
chance to take a look at it and I'm glad
we got to make this we will be doing
this more often on the show integrating
a note
and then writing in it if we have good
thoughts to integrate